Європейські компанії, які беруть участь в будівництві
"Північного потоку-2", вже незабаром можуть зіткнутися
з обмеженнями з боку США.
Ми, уряд Сполучених Штатів, виступаємо проти проекту
"Північний потік-2". Ми чітко дали зрозуміти, що фірми,
які працюють в російському енергетичному секторі,
можуть – якщо вони продовжать займатися цим бізнесом –
наразитися на санкції.
Внесення в обмежувальний список таких компаній
залишається одним зі спірних пунктів закону
"Про протидію противникам Америки шляхом санкцій".
Президент США Дональд Трамп
підписав цей документ у 2017 році.
Вашингтон керується не лише політичними,
але й економічними мотивами, вважають
у Німецькому інституті економічних досліджень у Берліні.
Є дві причини, чому американці виступають проти "Північного потоку-2".
По-перше, вони хочуть підтримати свою власну енергетику –
видобування газу методом фрекінгу.
В США сподіваються, що, якщо вони постачатимуть зріджений газ
у Європу, то зможуть краще впливати на ринок.
І "Північний потік-2" в цій ситуації – це більмо на оці.
Друга причина – політична ситуація щодо Росії.
І цей газопровід нині використовується як аргумент,
щоб виступати з іншими політичними заявами.
Головний лобіст "Північного потоку-2"
останнім часом у Німеччині –  політик Зіґмар Ґабріель –
втратив посаду голови МЗС.
Анґела Меркель, яку нещодавно вчетверте
переобрали канцлеркою, неодноразово підкреслювала
комерційний характер пректу.
На запит DW в міністерстві економіки Німеччини відповіли,
що стежать за заявами США.
Ми, як правило, не коментуємо думки чи висловлювання іноземних сенаторів.
Позиція уряду Німеччини щодо "Північного потоку-2", вважаю,
відома: це проект, який просувають приватні компанії.
Нові штрафні заходи щодо компаній експерти вважають
нині маловірогідними. Зірвати планування
"Північного потоку-2" тепер,
швидше за все, вже не вдасться.
Перемови досягли одного із завершальних етапів.
І все ж, експерти не виключають затримок
з проектом в майбутньому –
через активні політичні дискусії в Європі
та непрості відносини з Кремлем.